Você sofre com aquele zumbido no ouvido
que não te deixa em paz? Pois olha só o
que os cientistas estão testando agora.
Um ensaio clínico publicado na revista
Brain Sciences está avaliando uma nova
terapia sonora chamada Lints. E o
interessante que ela funciona de um
jeito diferente do que a gente conhece.
Em vez de usar sons altos para bafar o
zumbido, essa técnica os estímulos
sonoros quase imperceptíveis ajustados
exatamente na frequência do zumbido de
cada paciente. Veja bem, o zumbido não é
só um barulhinho chato. Quando ele é
crônico, ele afeta a memória, humor,
sono, qualidade de vida de forma
importante. Cerca de 10% das pessoas
convivem com isso diariamente. O que
essa terapia faz é tentar recondicionar
as vias auditivas do cérebro, ensinando
ele a ignorar aquele sinal. No estudo,
os participantes usaram aparelhos por
pelo menos 4 horas diárias durante
algumas semanas. Um dos pacientes
relatou silenciamento completo do
zumbido durante o uso e redução de quase
50% no incômodo após o tratamento. Ainda
precisa de mais estudos, mas é uma luz
no fim do túnel para quem convive com
esse problema há anos sem solução.